[Música]
con nuestra primera invitada del día
vamos a seguir analizando la situación
política de Brasil tras estas elecciones
generales del día de ayer domingo donde
Luisiana celular Silva y el actual
mandatarios se disputarán la presidencia
el próximo 30 de octubre en la segunda
vuelta de estas elecciones saludamos
entonces a Marcia Ribeiro y politóloga y
profesora de la universidad Federal del
estado de Río de Janeiro Gracias Marcia
por estar con nosotros esta mañana lunes
en directo América de France 24
empezamos por la lectura esta primera
vuelta de las elecciones y la
polarización del país cada vez más en
evidencia no Además fue cuando se hacen
pues elecciones en ese país
Buenos días gracias por la invitación
Bueno qué pasa
las encuestas prevían el resultado muy
próximo de que Lula o detenido y
la gran diferencia y los otros las otras
candidaturas también seguirán lo que se
prevía en las encuestas apenas
bolsonaron a sorprendido en sus
resultados y también o candidato Ciro
Gómez que es del campo de la izquierda
y que se esperaba que
sus electores pudieran al último momento
a ir con Lula y garantizar la elección
en primera vuelta en primera vuelta pero
no pasó lo que parece es que estos
electores al último momento han decidido
colocar sus votos en bolsonaron eso es
la más próxima evaluación que puedo
hacer porque el candidato que ha perdido
votos con relación a lo que se pedía era
Ciro Gómez tenía entre 6 y 7% en las
encuestas y ha hecho como 3%. ese estrés
por ciento pueden haber migrado a
bolsonaro
y por eso
más algunos indecisos
avergonzados que han dicho que habrían
de votar a él Marcia hablemos ahora de
la abstención el día de ayer en esta
primera vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales y yo también le quería
preguntar si digamos históricamente el
voto se ha comportado de esa manera
digamos abstención en primera vuelta
grande y ya en la segunda vuelta la
gente si se anima más a votar para
elegir Quién sería el presidente cómo lo
podemos ver el 30 de octubre y digamos
estas estos obsesionistas si se animan a
votar en la segunda vuelta hacia donde
se inclinarían hacia evolucionaron hacia
Lula
bueno era yo estudio a los
abstensionistas exactamente
el 20% es lo que
hemos tenido en 2000 de
mucho 18
y antes Entonces no está fuera de lo
esperado Pero mira en Brasil la votación
es obligatoria pero los electores pueden
hacer
dos cosas pueden votar en blanco o
anular a sus votos
elegindo un número
inexistente y bueno estas tazas fueron
mucho más bajas que en las otras
elecciones o que nos da una indicación
que los electores estaban más activos en
esta elecciones a pesar de la distinción
el no comparecimiento que se dicen
tener sido dentro de la media histórica
es lo mismo No no
aumentó ni ni has disminuido Pero así la
votación que llamamos
inválida que son los blancos en nudos
este sesión Bueno de hecho eso tenemos
una participación política más activa en
este año en comparación a 2018
entonces que que tenemos los ahora es el
momento de de porcionar El Lula y Buscar
estos votos
bueno todo puede pasar Claro pero el más
importante son las votaciones de
la candidata de bebé y los remanecientes
de Ciro Gómez creo que a una
probabilidad de
[Música]
apoyar a la candidato Lula o que va a
aumentar sus chances de ganar este votos
y
Gómez es imprevisible porque todo lo que
lo pasó
lo pone una situación muy difícil con la
cantidad de célula claro
digamos que todo podría apuntar a que el
expresidente adicional solo la Silva
Pues sería el ganador no el próximo 30
de octubre en el balotaje si es el
ganador Lula como tendría las cosas
dentro del Congreso que sabemos que
tenemos un congreso pintado ahora
conservador con una balanza más
inclinada hacia bolsonaro que tendría
que hacer Lula no que pactos A lo mejor
tendría que hacer o ni siquiera Hay
posibilidades de pacto dentro del
congreso para poder tener una gobernanza
más fácil
una vez elegido Lula su situación para
gobernar queda muy difícil no imposible
porque luna es un gran negociador pero a
la fuerza del conservadurismo en Brasil
se mostró mucho mayor que se esperaba
especialmente en los sectores de la
izquierda
se creía que Lula que había tenido una
gran transformación por los cuatro años
de gobernanza de gobierno de de
bolsonaro y todas las cosas difíciles
que Brasil está pasando pero al final no
pasó eso y la elecciones para la cámara
y el senado y los gobernadores de
Estados han revelado una fuerza todavía
muy grande
del conservadurismo en Brasil y
evolucionaron entonces que no va a ser
una tarea difícil fácil para Luna así
electo elector en
el próximo viaje